the jurogan experience this is something
a lesson we never learned in history
that we really should have but in
world war one woodrow wilson said he was
going to make the world safe for
democracy
that was the american mission in world
war one and at the time the
the world certainly was not safe for
democracy i mean europe was all
monarchs pretty much and we overthrew
the monarchs
the monarchy is pretty much lost and the
ones that are still there are like
monarchies and name only you know
england and stuff like that
um and then in the next decades you had
the rise
of hitler uh stalin or lenin and then
stalin
and you're like oh man those those
monarchs don't seem so bad all of a
sudden now you know
like oh [ __ ] it turns out you could get
rid of something and something much
worse can come
after it i need a full-length plan but
for obama
who even goes you know i think he
acknowledged at one point that libya was
his biggest mistake
and he said not having a plan for the
day after
uh gaddafi was overthrown was a big
mistake and it's like
yeah i sure wish we had just lived
through iraq
like how could you not see that coming
right how could how could you not be
like oh yeah and then after that
still tried to overthrow assad in syria
right and you're like oh yeah do you
remember when they gave that speech when
he gave a speech on television
and everybody was like [ __ ] this and
then they go
it kind of just went away it was one of
the most beautiful moments in
in modern american history people really
actually stood up and stopped
a war from happening yeah so instead
they just uh covertly funded
the al qaeda uh side of it jimmy dore
broke this down when he was on your show
perfectly
yes those guys who go like uh they they
tell the story of syria
and it's like the um you know mike baker
who i love but his version of the story
in syria
is like well assad started killing all
of his own people
and so what are we gonna do you know
like that's the story that they want to
tell you right it's like
this guy's just so bad he's killing all
these people you go is that really what
mike baker's version of it was
it wasn't it's a caricature of it but
that was more or less that's that's more
or less it right
i love mike baker by the way uh but uh
so that's
but the real story is that you go okay
so if we're there
if the narrative is that we're there
because assad's killing his own people
and oh my god i think he used a gas
attack or oh my god i think he did this
and this is really dangerous
well then why is it that general wesley
clark
is telling us on video that he saw plans
to have regime change in syria in 2003.
yeah that's why
dark video why are there articles in
2007 about regime
because he certainly wasn't killing his
own people then right and then as jimmy
dore broke down
perfectly you realize that actually what
happened was that the cia and the saudis
launched this operation timber sycamore
and they
they said that we are going to arm all
of the anti-assad
rebels largely consisting of al qaeda
and isis
in an attempt to take him out to have
the next regime change that has been
that this plan had been in the works for
years
and when confronted with that threat
assad launched a brutal war against them
certainly killed a whole lot of people i
mean like if there if there was isis in
a town he'd just kill everybody in the
town like he didn't care
um but the story is not as simple as
like oh he started killing his own
people
and so now we have to overthrow him the
story is we tried to overthrow him
and in response this war broke out where
something like 500 000 people died
was wesley clark was he running for
president when that happened
i if i'm not mistaken i believe he ran
before i could be wrong about that i
think was he one of the democratic
candidates in 2000
i believe so i believe this was after
after all that
that was a dark video when you saw him
laying out the foundation that they had
and the fact that he was willing to do
that and say it all in an interview on
television
yeah no it's really really creepy and
it's very hard to not look back at that
and go like okay well not all of it came
true exactly but certainly there has
been an agenda
since 9 11 to have one regime change
after the next
in the middle east it wasn't just oh we
have to go to afghanistan
and oh we also have to go to iraq
because we think they have wmds or
something
it's like well why then have there been
these five subsequent countries
that we also have to go and overthrow
and no one ever with the exception of
wesley clark
no no politician ever told the american
people
hey here's what our plan is yeah this is
what we want to do do you guys
agree with this or do you not agree with
this you have no say in this we're we're
doing this and each time we're going to
claim that it's completely just like oh
the humanitarian impulse the people
there
yeah the uh the difference between
what's happening now and in the past is
first of all there's so much video right
where you could see a guy like wesley
clark talk about that but also that you
can see
video of the events actually happening
like we have video of saddam hussein
being
hung we have video of gaddafi
being captured by those rebels where
they stick a knife up his ass
that video is that is one of the most
bizarre videos gadhafi
in shock not not even responding to the
fact that someone just stuck a knife up
his ass
like so just completely gripped with
terror
knowing that this is the end and that
the rebels have captured they're all
screaming and yelling and [ __ ]
going crazy well uh that's right and and
what's
happened is that the the corporate press
has lost their monopoly on information
that they had for all of our lives right
like now it's like well you can get it
from all these places
and that there's good and bad that comes
with that but
they're also now flipping out and and
you can see it like they're
losing their grip on power and becoming
more and more
insane about it well they've lost the
ethics of journalism like
like this james o'keefe thing on cnn
where that guy who
was he the chief whatever he is yeah i
forget his position but a big he was a
pretty big cnn guy
and the crazy thing is they catch him on
tinder dates
so they they hot it gets like she must
be hot
hot girls get you to talk so he's got
this hot girl and he's telling her
how they do propaganda how they
basically would accentuate anything that
was wrong with trump
they would talk about the completely
underplay anything that's wrong with
biden
which is which is to be fair pretty
obvious yeah to anyone who just has an
open mind and watches cnn but to hear
him
say it he still was it was powerful and
the fact that he said they're going to
do it now for climate change
wow and and there that push is already
starting
yeah um can you imagine just like if you
were like the head of cnn
and you have to give a meeting in the
morning and you're like all right so one
more time guys
if a hot chick takes you out to a bar
and starts asking you to tell her about
how we're propaganda that's that's james
o'keefe all right so please
please don't just start babbling about
how we do propaganda
it's so crazy it's just it's so weird to
see it laid out like that
where you know he's explaining how they
do it
but what a blabber mouth the fact that
this guy like
you know hey man this is kind of
important like
imagine if someone heard you say this
imagine what kind of repercussions it
would have on the business
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience